[Music]
Ricky Javas and Dave Chappelle have
released their specials and the internet
has once again lost its tiny little mind
people can't believe that these
comedians have always told offensive
jokes have gone on stage and told
offensive jokes of course Dave Chappelle
told a whole load of jokes about trans
people I'd be offended if he didn't
that's why a lot of people go and watch
his shows at this point Dave's entire
audience is probably made up of gender
critical feminists or as they're
Otherwise Known lesbians basically Dave
Chappelle's audience is made up of women
who look just like me asking Dave
Chappelle to not do trans jokes is like
going to watch a Trevor Noah show and
expecting jokes it ain't going to happen
and what his detractors don't understand
is this is half the reason he loves
doing them he loves pissing people off
and he knows that idiots are going to
Tweet about it demanding his
cancellation and other idiots are going
to deliver badly performed monologues to
camera trying to piggy back off his
success that's the currency of the
internet now it's not the quality of the
jokes it's how much notoriety you can
generate with your jokes the more you
piss people off the more likly they are
to share your material and not only that
you get a kick out of pissing people off
who you disagree with who doesn't love
reading a guardian article with the
title Dave Chappelle's trans jokes are
worse than being fisted by an SS guard
in aitz and it's basically a rant by
some non-binary girl who hates rich
white men because her dad's one and he
left her mom for a younger model every
time the New York Times hears that Dave
releases a new special they rub their
hands with Glee as they can write
another article about how a 50-year-old
black man has now joined the ranks of
white supremacy by punching down on
trans people this makes a welcome change
from writing articles about why Trump
has joined the ranks of white supremacy
there are only 3 m million times you can
write the same article before you and
your audience start to get a little
bored not the guardian they've written
that article 6 million times and it gets
more ejaculations from Their audience
than PornHub also DAV is Muslim and say
what you like about the religion of
Peace it's never been the most tolerant
when it comes to sexual minorities
compared to the average 50-year-old
Muslim in Saudi Arabia Dave is
hopelessly woke he should grow out
what's left of his hair Dy it blue get a
septum Pierce
and demand that the audience Don't Clap
as it triggers his PTSD then burst into
tears when they don't clap as they're
not appreciating his art the left aren't
the only ones to play this game scarcely
a week goes by without some tedious
winge bag on the right demanding that we
cancel a left wing comedian for being
unfunny the latest person to face this
ey is Rosie Jones Rosie is a comedian
with cerebral py this condition affects
the way she moves and the way she speaks
Rosie is also very liftwing and openly
Pro trans her material reflects this
worldview just like Ricky's and Dave's
reflects theirs that's what's great
about comedy it welcomes everyone and it
allows disabled people to take part
wonderful it also allows people with
learning difficulties to participate and
that's why we have Nish kummer I had a
bread roll thrown at me I realize this
is an offensive joke and I apologize as
someone who has been diagnosed with a
learning difficulty I'd be furious if
someone compared me to Nish Kumar every
comedian has their AUD
some people will love de Chappelle and
others will love Rosie Jones it's
subjective chill out the only thing you
need to know about comedians is this if
they're male and they do material about
being a male feminist they're a sex
offender this rule applies every single
time every time you see a comedian talk
about what a great guy is and how he
respects women audiences should act like
they're on the Titanic get the hell out
and make sure the women and children go
first Ricky V is someone who has also
addressed controversial subject matter
in his standup making jokes about
left-wing people supporting illegal
immigration and Gary ler apparently this
now makes him rightwing the last time I
checked illegal immigration was illegal
and Gary liner is a multi-millionaire
former footballer and celebrity since
when did taking the piss out of
celebrities with demented opinions
become right wing 2016 when both Ricky
and Dave would have been considered
lefties until we all lost our our tiny
little minds and drank so much Kool-Aid
none of us know who we are anymore and
can't even answer a question as simple
as what is a woman which ironically is
the only question I got correct on my
high school biology exam because whilst
I may have learning difficulties I'm not
Nish Kumar before you go let me take a
minute to recommend a longevity
supplement by Versa in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging all
together and that's why I'm using Verso
Verso is a company that translates these
incredible scientific breakthroughs into
products that hold the potential to
increase your longevity and one of their
products that I take every day is called
cell beinging cell beinging helps combat
aging by increasing something called NAD
Plus in your body now NAD is ARG be the
most important molecule in your body
high NAD levels improve your metabolism
repairs damaged DNA and increases energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
D plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
this video Plus Vero publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join me you can get
15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use code trigger to save 15% off
your order and if you enjoyed that then
watch this video where I talk about how
the demand for racism seems to have
outstripped the
[Music]
supply